good afternoon everyone welcome to
cabinet it is now 3:30 so we can start
the meeting
so item 1 on the agenda apologies for
absence nonchalant thank you and it's
good to see everyone here item 2
disclosures of interest any disclose of
interest counselor house item 24 welcome
Matt furred airfield
I would declare that I have been a
member of the thank you councillor house
noted minutes confirm and signed the
minutes of the meeting held on the 5th
of November is everyone happy with the
minutes in that case many degrade
matters to be referred to the council
planning and building services portfolio
councillor Pemberton Harbury and Deb's
bridge Neighborhood Development Plan
thank you very much chairman I'm going
I'm going old school with paper now so
numbers this item is before you for the
adoption with immediate effect of the
Harbury and Depot's Bridge Neighborhood
Development Plan which went through its
referendum and I've just been searching
for the results
right so yes the referendum was on the
29th of November and the local plan was
endorsed with a ninety four point zero
five percent yes votes eight hundred and
twenty two votes yes versus fifty two no
votes and had generated by a turnout of
forty one point six five percent which
is quite a high turnout for a
Neighborhood Development Plan its
thirteenth one that we've had so far
and whilst I don't have the full league
table to my to my fingertips my memory
serves me as one of the highest turnouts
we've had for a development plan and it
would like to place on record my thanks
to the members of the Harbury and
deckers bridge Neighborhood Development
Plan group for all of the work that
they've done in bringing this this plan
to a successful conclusion I'm not aware
that we have anybody to speak from nope
okay
unless Jackie no okay so on that on that
basis unless there are any questions and
are we enjoying our lunch chairmen in
the absence of any any questions from
anybody around the room about the plan
so then the recommendation is that the
Harbury and depths bridge neighborhood
development plan is adopted with
immediate effect and therefore that it
becomes part of the development plan for
stratford-upon-avon district given given
that we have no choice but to say yes
can all council members please say yes
yes good and that was a recommendation
to council as outlined on page 13 so we
now move on to item five
stratford-upon-avon Neighborhood
Development Plan councillor Pemberton
again I'm almost tempted to say ditto
however members this is again
a Neighborhood Development Plan
stratford-upon-avon neighbor development
plan which has gone through its
referendum process again referendum
heard on the 29th of November a 91 point
to 1% yes votes which was five thousand
two hundred and thirty nine votes yes to
five hundred and five votes no with a
small number of rejected ballot papers
the ballot generated to turn out of
twenty six point one one percent I do
note that councillor fragile II has
moved to the front of the room so on
that basis before however I I give way
to cancer-free G I would again want to
ensure that it is recorded my thanks and
offices thanks and this authorities
thanks for the huge amount of work done
this was a considerable piece of work
done it's it's the main Center for the
district and consequently the
Neighborhood Development Plan does bring
with it a number of complexities and a
huge workload for the group involved so
many thanks to them to bringing it to a
conclusion and virtually before council
if Anjali speaks can I just declare an
interest on this as I'm all atone
counselor counselor fragile II just
wanted to be because it's a momentous
occasion for the town to have this
development plan approved by such a
majority and to say really thank you to
the community because this is very much
a community led project which has taken
several years I think for members of the
local community really gave up four
years of their lives to get this to the
point where it is and to say a great
deal of thanks to the district as well
for shepherding it through and making
sure that it was in the right condition
to get the positive vote that it did and
really thanks all ran for it Thank You
councillor fragile II so so with that
members of cabinet the recommendation is
that the stratford-upon-avon
Neighborhood Development Plan is adopted
with immediate effect with the
consequence that it becomes part of the
development Pantha Stratford district
and that's a recommendation to to cancel
can I have your approval members of
cabinet good thank you
agenda item six development requirements
supplementary planning document adoption
of Parts A B and P and you counselor
Pemberton once again thank you make it
so members of the cabinet you will all
be aware that as part of the the core
strategy we are required to provide to
prepare and publish supplementary
planning documents and the purpose of
this item is to bring forward the
delivery of a number of those planning
documents to be adopted there is a fair
amount of work involved in bringing
these to fruition and there was
principally a choice around whether
those be brought forward as one but in
conjunction with officers it was felt
that there was still further work to be
done on other parts of the drastic
drastic draft SPD's and that it would be
it would be more beneficial to bring
forward the matters that have been dealt
with already so that we can have those
as policy documents that we can we can
refer to so it talks about as has been
at one before ABG JLM NP and you pull us
the deletion of the household the
guidance from the supplementary planning
documents that was in relation to and
response to feedback on the consultation
which felt that actually it would be
more appropriate and more user-friendly
for for our residents for the house
other guidance to be removed from the
formal SPD and to be brought forward as
user guidance on the on the website I do
see that councillor Morse has moved
forward and assumed
something that he wishes to ask and at
that point probably best to defer to
councillor Moore's councillor Moscow
Chairman Thank You chairman I'm more
concerned about what's not included
today than what is included in
particular on an S which are assuming
those housing mix chairmen which has
been delayed deferred general and local
housing needs general we simply be
running into problems again on housing
mix I understand the council is no
taking the view that unless housing mix
were specified at the time of outline
planning permission we are no longer in
a position to enforce the core strategy
guidelines I'm wondering when we bring
forward s will it solve this problem and
what do we do in the meantime chairman
to try and get the housing mix that we
read down in the core strategy it was
based on local need what do we do to
make sure that developers follow that
housing mix second point chairman is on
air quality number R again it's delayed
German you'll be a well aware that we're
cancelling the air quality management
area in Stratford town could we have an
undertaking that that will not take
place until is supplementary planning
document covering air quality is
introduced so two points there chairman
thank you
in the paperwork it's got design as long
Martin some two years ago we had and
that is graceful 20 years it be designed
at a meeting with the company and an
officer another officer to done the work
and we feel we got it right they just
finished building it different types and
changes last Wednesday there were five
thousand suddenly which were atrocious
in design appalling there was no design
to it and as you well know that was
concerned about another application
which I can't speak too much about being
on the committee but I do feel that we
need to in
area look more at design if you want to
look at the 20 asses that are being
built by an Irish company which was
bland on the entireties and we changed
it to what we feel is right and it's
turning out right I would wish you to
come and look but we do need you to
design in my respects he's lucky in some
of these applications Thank You
councillor Barnes councillor Pemberton
would you care to respond I think thank
you very much
picking up the question of housing mix
so as as members will be aware because
there has been a briefing sheet issued
as I understand it there was a there was
an appeal decision which has had the
effect that we're mix is not whether
it's been an outline application if mix
was not addressed at that point the ship
has sailed
I am advised that that that has been an
issue in two applications but in terms
of the broad mixes that have been
achieved and agreed at outline stages we
are there or there about what I will
commit to doing is that producing full
members of the cabinet and for wider
circulation and some broad analysis if
you will of the extent to which the that
has become an issue certainly more
recently planning officers aware of who
are aware obviously aware of the
decision and are ensuring that the mix
is is is taken as an as an item at the
outline stage so I think that yes it has
it has cropped up in two recent
applications it was gold post being
moved somewhat by an appeal decision and
we have to react to that and certainly
as a broad principle and the policy
officers at the back of the room he's
aware of changes the the aim is that all
of our supplementary planning documents
are is up-to-date and as future proof as
possible clearly as I say things do move
so with the best will in the world any
one of these policies could be
superseded by an appeal decision and we
then
just have to have we just have to react
to that we're not in control of that
because they're not necessarily
decisions within our own district these
are decisions handed down elsewhere so
insofar as were able to whittle
future-proof all the planning documents
and certainly I think we're aware of
that particular issue on the housing mix
you will you then mentioned air quality
and I think that that's something opera
I just need to come back to you on as
far as that's concerned just to give you
an update
certainly not my portfolio in terms of
controlling the air quality management
I think decide the Mike or Jackie
thought it might be might be better for
one of those two to just jump in here
before I say something mr. perch do you
wish to comment yes certainly there are
no current intentions to cancel the air
quality management area it may be a
decision that's taken from us because
it's based on sort of levels that we
report we haven't been reaching that the
levels required to justify the meta
Quality Management area in recent year
so we might be issued with an
instruction but currently we have no
instruction we have no intention of
cancelling that error at the moment
report back that changes most of careful
Thank You leader and if I can just give
calcium or some comfort the draft SPD
did include a section on air quality and
further workers have been undertaking on
that front and that further work is far
more detailed and aligned with the
consultation responsibly we caught in it
is felt that we may need to revisit that
section and have a much more detailed
section a standalone section rather than
a small section so that's why it's not
included in today's papers that
certainly is it is high on officers
agenda and it's something we will look
at in greater detail and bring back to
Kathleen intercourse so are you saying
mr. Carrisford that when the air quality
SPD is published it will be far more fit
for purpose then it may well have been
before my words certainly far more
detailed and for more useful in that
sense yes thank you mr. ki Fateh
councillor francelli just going back to
housing mix for a second perhaps well I
know that this does have slightly
different figures in it which are
supported by consultation papers so when
you're considering fixing housing
numbers in the future that the
development plans will be taken into
consideration
in the fixing of those numbers and not
just refer to the core strategy in this
in that case presumably in the absence
of anything in outline permission the
neighborhood plants have no more weight
and the core strategy has he makes that
would be correct yeah going I mean the
general I mean as far as the general
certainly said the question about
relying on neighborhood development
plans
absolutely yes we will be taking account
of Neighborhood Development plans
they're an important part of the whole
process and we seek to achieve the
housing mix that has been set in policy
there is a slight divergence between the
Stratford plan and the core strategy and
I think we just that would have to deal
with that on a case-by-case basis in
terms of you know what can be achieved
moving on to Kansas I think does that
address as far as mixes concern I mean
just to reinforce we as an authority are
backing the mix that we we've set out in
our core strategy and we seek to achieve
that as best as we possibly can in all
the circumstances we can moving to
Kansas the balance point about the
quality of design I'm bound to say that
design is always in the eye of the
beholder and it is the most difficult
thing to put together in a policy
because it is exactly that you eat one
person's one person's grand design is
another person's car and the thing is
cast the bombs every member in this
council feels they know what's right
having said that it is very clearly the
sort of wish of this authority that in a
position where we have a core strategy
that's in place in a position where we
have now 13 neighborhood development
plans in place in a situation where we
have a five-year housing land supply in
place that we push and back our policies
as far as we can and the the officers
through the head of service and that and
the and the planning teams are being
encouraged to be more and more and more
assertive about the quality of design
that comes through again it's a
subjective thing and it is quite true to
say that the the designs that come
forward subcommittees are not always
ones that meet with the approval of the
committee's and that is there
right to make a decision on that I don't
think it's true to say that bad design
is just being pushed through on the nod
I do think there are designs coming
through from schemes that were
permissioned in a previous environment
where we didn't have a core strategy etc
etc so there is some sort of what's
what's coming through more more recently
I think we are we are achieving better
design but it is very much in the in the
in in in the context that that is an
entirely subjective decision for those
who are then the decision makers so
officers will do their best to achieve
the best quality design but there are
constraints people like quite cautious
designs in this district there you know
there is a relatively cautious
vernacular for for for design so you
know in either different types of
innovation struggle so I think it is
going to be a continuing discussion
about design Thank You councillor sorry
counselor kettle sorry Thank You mr.
chairman
I'm concerned once again about an
inspector seeking to rewrite the rules
of the core strategy whilst we fully
understand this one goes to the the high
court route in the specs of decision on
an initial planning application is cast
in stone we can't do anything about it
just have to accept it whether we
believe it right or wrong but we're an
inspector is actually by making a
decision casting doubt on that policy
and housing its policy if it isn't
agreed at the outline stage that gives
me a lot of cause concern because we do
know that inspectors got it wrong we do
know in the reading case which I was
looking at some time ago about 12 months
ago there was no ability to overturn
that decision but the planning the
spectrum did spend that send that
particular inspector off for retraining
he got it wrong on housing mix in that
case only councillor kettle how does
this fit into the
development requirements SP days this is
racing to housing mix okay so in that
case the inspector man reading was sent
off to be retrained we see got it wrong
they couldn't transition but trying to
prove it next time run where something
like this is far more fundamental and
actually looking at a whole lot of
future cases might it be worth
considering whether in the event that
inspectors the decision was actually
wrong and was not intended to change the
core strategy whether we should consider
going to the Inspectorate and saying is
this was was this supposed to happen
counselor Pemberton thank you so I think
just just to be clear housing mix is one
of the areas that we're going to come to
so it's not one that's been looked at
today in terms of housing mix and the
decision what the inspector said was if
you don't address housing mix at the
outline stage you've chosen not to do
that that ship has sailed that decision
was not challenged by the authority
involved nor as have been challenging
any other living and actually it's it's
a fairly sensible thing if you you know
you if you want if you want to ensure
you've got your house and makes you nail
it down at the first opportunity going
to your broader point about has about
planning inspectors changing course
strategies I'm afraid we have the system
that we have and in broad terms the
planning inspectors have the pen of the
Secretary of State and I make that they
are they are pretty much the final
arbiter of this thing there are
mechanisms open to us as an authority
whereby if any decision came forward
that was contrary or detrimental to our
plan and our policies we have and if we
believe that decision to be erroneous we
do have a roots and I am aware of one
such circumstance that is being
considered at this point I'm not in a
position to say more than that at this
point but I think to give assurance to
the chair that we're we ever felt that
the inspector was going off the
reservation and it was going to be
detrimental to us we would seek to act
in any way shape that we could I'm not
there's much more we can do I'm just
writing to the planning inspector it's a
well you know you've got a lot of power
you got to be careful about how you use
it not sure how much that's going to
change their view I take on board what
you say and I think we just have to be
able to deal with circumstances as they
arise councilor careful think you've
answered question but I think if it was
the intention of the planning inspectors
at the highest levels to sort of pull
the rug from under core strategies by
changing it to outline the development
may not have put a scheme in at outline
in terms of legacy majors gone to the
principal development on that site this
is a very serious issue which I think we
need to consider not necessarily by
ourselves but as local authorities
whether if we get the stage we're
planning inspectors and I'll go back to
the point where the planning inspector
Inspectorate of knowledge inspectors
have made mistakes that we should seek
clarifications well this is intentional
or not intentional because it could go
wrong by by default because that the
original app could never put store
housing mix on stage and therefore by
not doing so we effectively stuffed I
think your point has been made
councillor kettle and I do take some
reassurance from or councillor pemberton
says that we may well be considering
[Music]
taking up a planning inspectors decision
in another way and I think that is all
to the good as to the wider point about
whether or not councils if I infer from
what you said that council should get
together to raise issues I think that is
a another matter all-together
so with that
I'm sorry
in terms of item six and the
recommendations to the council
do I have cabinets approval to take
those forward to Council agreed good
thank you
item seven which is the statement of
community enrollment under once again we
have council offender two there was it
always a bad night so members so this is
a review and refresh of our statement of
community involvement it's the process
that it sets out the process by which we
as a council to intend to engage with
our communities through the planning
process the statement was last revised
in 2014 and this update reflects changes
in regulations and legislation and best
practice and identifies a number of
changes and those are set out in
appendix appendices one and two and the
recommendation is that the changes
identified are formally abductive
adopted into a 2018 version of the
statement of community involvement
I do have officers here with me to be
able to answer any questions if I
struggle but any other questions any
questions any discussion in that case
moving to the recommendation on page 27
the council approves the changes
identified and formally adopts the
statement of community involvement
can I have cabinets agreement to
recommend that to council please thank
you
cabinets so moving on now to item 8 and
this time it is not councillor Pemberton
it is councillor house thank you very
much later I shall do my best not to
follow councillor Pemberton with too
much detail on this item eight is the
local industrial and economic strategy I
think the acronym is
little bit unfortunate but work it out
for yourselves firstly what I would like
to do is to congratulate Rosalie
Williams who's the officer the policy
officer that produced this excellent
piece of work considerable amount of
work went in it's been out to the
consultation and it's come back and it's
now in its final draft it's a timely
piece of work as it coincides not only
with the W and say W MC a industrial
strategy but also the UK's Stratford
District Council locally is taking a big
lead in this and it is the only council
so far and contrary were sure to have
actually prepared the local strategy the
strategy sets have out how it will work
with partners and local businesses to
deliver the jobs we need the growth that
we need and also to address the problem
of productivity and to get increased
productivity the strategy sets out three
visionary aims which are listed in your
papers one the best place to start and
grow a business so it's the business
aspect to prosperous communities the
vision of place and three good jobs and
earning power these are based on the
well-known management principles of
where are we now where do we want to be
and what are the ways of getting there
there's no doubt that we do face quite a
few problems in the future and there's
no need for me to list them out you're
all aware of them and by having a
strategy like this it means that we can
give those our best possible opportunity
of achieving the the right outcomes so
this strategy aligns itself with our
core strategy which runs up to two
thousand thirty one and it is the
intention of this council to review this
strategy every five years so members
were ready to rock and roll with this
the future's looking very very bright
and I'll pass it back to you leader for
the recommendations to the council Thank
You councillor house can I just draw
members attention to the note on agenda
item that
there are some amendments that need to
be made to the printed version these are
on this sheet the online version is
correct can I just follow up by saying I
also thought this is an impressive piece
of work
I think the link through to the lap on
the Dublin MCA does give us some
potential for leverage and I also
thought looking through it the responses
to the consultation appeared very
thorough and it does seem to me that
that consultation process and the
connections and contacts made will stand
us in good stead going forward with that
are there any points for discussion or
questions in which case can I move to
the recommendation to Council on page 31
that we the council approves the changes
identified or formally adopts a local
industrial economic strategy the
stratford-on-avon district 2018 231 kind
of have your approval members of cabinet
please great thank you
and moving on to item 9 I believe we
return to councillor Pemberton thank you
chairman I shall take the less than
subtle hint from council house to be
brief so members this is an item
relating to the local development scheme
its which is a work program that
provides information around the local
plan and development plan documents that
this council produces there is a there
are a number of pieces of work that are
that have been completed they are the
along side the long Martin Airfield and
the canal quarter however there are some
items where there has been some slippage
notably the Gypsy and traveller plant
gypsy and traveller plan and development
requirements SPD and a number of the so
this alongside a number of others have
been
retimed tabled the slippage has arisen
partially because of time taken to
complete and secure key technical
background information specifically the
strategic housing land availability
assessment and then when we start to
look forward in terms of the
consultations that we must undertake for
each of these documents it is now quite
clear that we are going to run up to a
point where noting that we have an
election in May we are going to run into
the perder period and particularly when
we consider the site allocations plan
that's that piece of work is quite
significant
on that basis officers up have looked at
the the work that is involved to see
whether it is realistic for us to get to
a position where before we're going to
purdah that the these documents can be
produced and the short answer to that is
that now they can't so we are proposing
that those documents be considered post
of May we are also reminded to take into
account the fact that we will have a
minimum of 15 new members in this
Authority from my with the number of
members stepping down and so given the
the nature and complexity and strategic
importance of some of these documents
from a Democratic standpoint there is a
feeling that and it is far more
appropriate that what is in essence a
new council has the opportunity to
consider these key documents early on in
the in the life of the new Authority to
give some transparency and to and to
provide some certainty you will note at
point one point eight in the report
the revised timetable for the site
allocations plan and the [ __ ] and
Traveller plan has been provided where
we are shooting for council and cabinet
approval by july that next year
submission of the pre consultation at
the pre submission consultation to be
concluded during August and September
and to be in a position where the
submission
is concluded by the end of 2019 that
then gets us into 2020 where we are
anticipating an examination process
sometime between January and July with
adoption anticipated somewhere between
May and October and that's obviously
dependent upon how early how close to
January the inspector can kickoff and
how long that work takes clearly those
two last items are outside of our
control and there may be some flex in
there I'll take any questions or
observations come counselor more sorry
well you're sitting you are sitting
there too expectantly councillor walls a
chairman I think I can see sites and
site allocations plan Chairman we're now
talking about possibly towards the end
of 2020 before we get any resolution on
these matters I'm sure we all aware that
the dangerous position this puts us in
when people bring forward sites
especially on [ __ ] sites that in the
lack of an allocated plan or KB sites on
a plan we are open to challenge almost
any way would be quite distressed by
that equally Chairman is disappointing
that can be an action in Maine residents
will not have the opportunity to pick
these issues up at the election that may
seem some people chairman but I think
presidents will be very unhappy if they
suddenly discover some major site
allocations just after the election has
taken place they will perhaps be a be
justified in that complaint could I ask
German are we making all resources
necessary to push these two areas ahead
with all possible speed
the short answer yes we are some some
comfort in certainly in terms of the
Gypsy and traveler as we know it a call
for sites has not drawn any and anything
forward on the flip side there has not
been any great rush to bring huge
numbers of sites forward in fact that
that seems to a you know quiet and down
in the sense of fewer applications are
coming forward we have to get it right
in terms of finding the right sites and
officers are doing as much as they
possibly can bringing more officers in
for example isn't going to change this
on that basis members what we're looking
for
if there are no other observations is
that the timetable for the preparation
of the local plan documents as outlined
in this report are approved and that the
strap at on Aven local district local
development scheme is revised
accordingly and that revised local
developments can be brought into effect
in accordance with section 15 bracket 7
close bracket of the planning and
compulsory purchase act 2004 bracket as
amended close bracket can I have your
approval to recommend this to Council
thank you so moving on now to item 10
Shakespeare's Henry Street project match
funding
councillor Cargill thank you chairman
the joint bid was made by the Coventry
warrant to the warranty warranty left by
SDC and Shakespeare Birthplace trust and
has been accepted in principle if the
match funding has proposed today is
agreed this funding will allow for a
major improvements to Henry Street which
is a main tourist destination in
Stratford
it's generally accepted that Henry
Street does not necessarily kept pace
with modern visitor expectations and
needs a major upgrade
for reference there were four successful
bids under the 22 applications to the CW
LEP two of which are here in Stratford
the other successful bid is for the
chapter theatre costume workshops which
is excellent news
the proposal by Shakespeare Birthplace
closed for those would both
significantly improve the area and
implement additional and upgraded
hostile vehicle measures improving
security and bringing it in line with
modern standards for pedestrian safety
there is also an aspiration for this bid
to kick start over Shakespeare related
initiatives in Stratford if a adopted
the proposals should see significant
improvement in the visitor experience an
increase in jobs was therefore treated
urgent business not subject calling it
all means chairman that there was a
considerable lack of consultation or all
these plans I'm wondering chairman if
there are any plans to consult with
people now on the implications of this
particularly local restauranteurs who
may be a bit dismayed to find that they
have a new competitor on their doorstep
who is being very substantially
subsidized by state aid and if I were a
restauranteur chairman I might be
somewhat concerned to find that now I
see mr. Webb is shaking his head on I'd
be delighted to be corrected chairman
that they are not receiving state aid
thank you so
kilomoles do stories are Jewish too so
just some kiss on the state ABC well to
two points I guess one is about the
timing of the bids is that the council
Moss is right that there was a lag in
terms of when the council first aware
that there was a pipeline there was a
call for pipeline projects and the
council explored a number of other
potential projects until they got to the
point where bar we this particular
project in Hammonds trade came to the
fore and that was towards the that was
two or three months into the process the
left in terms of awarding one you go
through all of the due diligence
including looking at state aid and we've
not been made aware of any issue in
button yeah thank you
I mean I think the reality is that
people come all over the world to
shakespeare's birthplace and you know
the birthplace trust are in a direct
competition with the globe in London
they're not coming to the restaurant on
Henry Street and if there is to be any
business in the restaurants on Henley
Street this oppositeworlds place we need
wills place because it becomes part of a
landmark destination otherwise they end
up going to the glut people will be
going to the globe in London and neither
of those businesses are going to thrive
and survive mr. Webb is that the this
whole concept of the Wills kitchen is
still in the whole concept that has been
worked up and I think it's unfair to
he bags that as another escort because
there are all sorts of other aspects
attached to that which include skills
education and a whole range of different
things so I don't I don't believe that
you're looking at a just another
restaurant in Stratford I think the
aspirations are greater than that only
opportunity is still there to consult
with local restaurant owners about this
can't answer that specifically
councillor Morse but what I would say is
that this project did come about at
fairly short notice it needed working up
you will be aware that we have actually
made submissions to the lek before not
being successful I think it is extremely
good that this one has been successful
and I have to say we will work in right
up until the last minute before
submission to get it completed in fact I
believe I signed it off on the very last
day it is also very important given the
competitive nature of tourism there we
actually do seek to invest quite heavily
in Stratford particularly in envy street
and I would endorse the point that has
been made by mr. Webb
at the moment they plans for wills
kitchen are if you like under
development but it is certainly intended
to be more than just a restaurant so I
think we will wait and see what the
birthplace trust finally can come up
with but personally I think this is
excellent news for Stratford and to be
quite honest I think it should only be
the start of substantial additional
investment in the town if we are to
maintain our position in the tourism
market with that then almost there any
more comments please can I have your
approval to the recommendation to
Council or the recommending
to counsel on page 51 much filming of
192,000 from the council's capital
reserve for the Shakespeare's Hamlet
Street project is agreed and subject to
the approval of Council for match
funding the grant offer from Coventry
and Warwickshire lap in relation to
Shakespeare's Henry Street project is
accepted Thank You members of cabinet so
now moving on to item 11 which is the
review of Stratford on Aven district
Housing Strategy and this is councillors
Harris and Pemberton who is going to
lead council Harris thank you
Thank You leader I think it's a
straightforward what is required from
the recommendations it's just basically
the report be noted and that the revised
milestones in the review of the housing
strategy 2015 2020 s at the first in
November 2018 be able to adopted
councillor Pemberton
any discussion any comments any
questions I'll take that as a no in that
case the recommendations on page 55 are
that the report be noted and that the
revised milestones in the review of
Housing Strategy 2015 to 20 as at the
1st of November 2018 be adopted can I
have your agreement members of cabinet
thank
Thank You jelly generally this is a good
news report I think we are doing very
well overall there are a few area of
concerns where targets are either not
being achieved or not on target with
regards to housing benefits to a council
tax reduction scheme this has not been
reported on as an assessment is to be
made of the accuracy of syndicator to be
monitored in the future and I will be
looking into that particular point the
other one though is the percentage of
home choice plus applicants notify
within 10 days has not been achieved and
I will undertake a review of this of the
previous targets set to see if this is
achievable in the future I think it's
only some concerns there and I would
like to live with more information on
that to find out what's going on there
otherwise I feel that is a positive
report we are on track to achieve our
targets and I would like to compliment
the officers on the hard work and
obviously all the portfolio holders and
poor fellows for the work that's gone
into this and obviously the significant
number of targets that already have been
met thank you Jim I did get the
impression that councillor Moss wishes
to speak the first one chairman is page
84 the land charge searches Jevon which
are at 9.2 8% meeting the turnaround
target the government's turn a target of
10 working days percent I see we're now
at nine point two eight percent today is
that just a refinement of the figures or
is the actual service deteriorating
further that's one question and the
second point chairman on page 86 the
insurance Plus applications notified of
a decision within 10 working days
chairman and in the summer it was taken
I'm concerned that by changing the
target for the whole of the year it
might be misleading I think many members
might find it more interesting if we
were just to start again from now and
measure the position from now to the end
of the year which might give a more
meaningful presentation of things how
things are actually going picking up
your point on that - councillor Morse
I'll pick up that one person and then go
to do I know the request was made I said
no because I don't I just want certainty
I need to know where we where the base
is where the problems lie and we can
move it on from there it's a good point
you've made and yes that was one of the
things I was looking at thinking where
do we baseline it from from now is it
sensible to do it within now and the
next three or four months before the end
of the next reporting period I will look
into that but you know so you're right I
think we do need to know we do need to
look at it and I'd like to count so
Pemberton
to have a discuss about the lung charges
please Castle Pemberton the portfolio
holder for poison chalice poisoned
chalices even an insurer actually the
service is improving so that those those
numbers have improved since that
reporting period and it is well known
and well documented that the service is
not performing to standard there is a
program of work which both talks around
and I team a service an IT system
implementation which is still on
schedule for delivery for the end of the
year and for the officers to be using
that there's also a plan in place to
address the backlog that exists and I
had my last briefing from Earth the from
full as the lead officer on this on
Friday and there are key meetings and
key milestones being set
so I'm confident that as we move into
the next reporting period will be seen
we'll be seen an upturn but yeah it's
work it's a work in progress but just to
just to be clear the officers are doing
absolutely everything that is within
their power to bring the service back up
to service standard and and then it will
be kept there it is just where we are
any more questions any more debate on
corporate strategy monitoring and that
case the recommendations on page 71 one
to four I'm not going to read them out
because everyone I am sure has a copy in
front of them and can read them so our
members of cabinet happy with those
recommendations thank you
cabinet moving on now to item 13 general
parking service management arrangements
counselor brain in 2014 which Haven
District Council with permission to
deliver the parking Affairs function as
part of the Chara arrangement to manage
Park and following the charges brought
of changes brought about the Mercer
County Council to change the on street
parking management arrangements since
2014 a number of requirements to parking
management have been carried out
including adjustments to the patrol in
Arrangements the insertion of new
equipment of Bridgeway car park the
replacement of plan display machines and
the introduction of credit card payments
and pay by phone these change of assist
in making the parking services more
efficient and improved the levels of
income generated by the service in the
final phase of the current proposals who
suggested that the back-office support
function provided by which aid and
district council is refined and that a
five-year service legal agreement is put
into place entered into these
arraignment rangers will allow us
access to better contract terms for
items such as software which will
largely offset the additional cost of
the announced arrangements it also
released some internal stuff time which
will be diverted to the other key
projects these opposed rules will
improve the service for our customers
allow us to develop the parkin service
in line with the aspirations of this
caveny and the recommendation back to
you leader Thank You counselor brain any
comments any discussion any questions
I'll take that as a resounding no in
that case the recommendation on page 89
that the proposed parking service
management arrangement set out in the
report are approved can I have your
agreement please cabinet thank you
cabinets moving on now to item 14 the
build relationship you counselor brain a
short one
following request by the Covenant
cabinet a review ability provision which
strategist C has been carried out the
attacks report has considered that
provision in an around the district and
there they relate to the needs of the
current population and projected
population of the 2031 in line with the
council's core strategy the report will
you be used to inform investment
decisions and the Kansas active
communities strategy I hand the
recommendation that you'd leader I think
before we do that it looks as though
counselor most once again wish used to
speak we have condition reviews
condition surveys
centers in the district and in every
category every every site everything is
above average every single criteria by
which we judge is above average no
German that's not really coming in with
some of the comments I get about the
Stratford Leisure Centre and changing
conditions and the changes in the rest I
just wondered who did the survey that
says it all for sites every category of
measurement is above average mr. perks
the surveys related to the facilities
themselves the the quality of the
facilities I imagine the complaints that
you're afraid to catch the most might
refer to the cleaning of the solicitors
sometimes questions so certainly in the
question of Stratford where we've got
the highest ratings the facilities were
built to sort of very rich men to sort
of modern standards whether they're
managed as well as the facilities have
the capacity to be is is probably a
different matter from the actual
condition survey which was being
monitored by this this work Thank You
councillor moss
Thank You councillor Morrissey it is
nice to get a compliment
in that case cabinet moving on to the
recommendation on page 111 that the
built later review is considered and
endorsed can I have your agreement
please members of cabinet great thank
you moving on now to item 15 which is
the active community strategy 20 19 to
24 and councillors a brain and Thank You
councillor Bray
leader the active community strategy the
current active community strategy
expires at the end of 2018 the proposed
replacement Saturday runs through until
2024 is attached I'm sure you've already
the subtly said aspirations for the
council Sports and Leisure Services
which shows that the council used a
function to contribute to improving
health and well-being from my colleague
over the road within the district the
cabins are asked to endorse the strategy
including the action plan for the first
year mr. perks the strategy focuses more
on sort of the ledger series rather than
sort of the built facilities there
wouldn't be any and provisions within
that community strategy to build a
ledger centers for example in other
areas what it would seek to do is make
sure that the sort of the soft the
provisions things like the walk programs
the interventions that we may
availability of play areas outdoor gym
equipment that type of stuff would be so
spread throughout the district to sum it
to some extent yes but I wouldn't want
to lead you to think we were going to
build a ledger centers throughout the
district yes the strategy does seek to
sort of cover the whole district to make
sure that everybody from sort of craters
great has the availability of exercise
and Club facilities and that's other
thing Thank You mr. Burke's with that
then councillors can we look at the
recommendations on page 153 and I assume
you can read them because they printed
there so can I have your agreement to
these recommendations please thank you
councillors moving on
to item 16 this is safeguarding and
child protection policy camps Maharis
Thank You leader as you can see this
report provides a summary of the revised
safeguarding in child protection policy
can I remind everyone that this policy
is underpinned by primary and secondary
legislation national policy and guidance
and it's weaved into the partnership
working on commitments we have with
other bodies
I think the document speaks for itself
the options are at point two but the
recommendations are in the front pages
you can say and I'd ask you to consider
those recommendations Thank You
councillor Harris any comments questions
or debate no in that case taking the
recommendations on page 197 can I have
your agreement to the recommendations
please cabinet thank you
item 17 again council Henry serve
Warwickshire safeguarding adults board
and you will report November 2017 to 18
Chancellor Harris thank you leader as
you can see this follows on really from
the last policy is one of our partners
that we work it with and are represented
at and the recommendation is that the
importance of the safeguarding adults
agenda is noted and a commitment to
remaining a participant in the activity
of the Warwickshire safeguarding outers
Adil's board is renewed and put it back
to you
Parris in that case the recommendation
on page 2 to 7 can I have your agreement
to the recommendation please members of
cabinet Thank You members of cabinet
item 18 which is the Austin Neighborhood
Development Plan pre-submission
consultation responses and we return to
counselor Thank You leader normal
service has been resumed
members before you is the Ulster
neighborhood development plan which has
reached the pre-submission council
station you might say that's easy to say
the pre-submission consultation response
stage that's to say where the
neighborhood development plan group has
broadly set out its plan and as we as an
authority have reviewed that and are
providing comments and observations to
inform the the next draft of the of the
development plan I'm not aware of
anybody here to speak however I have had
some correspondence from the Clark at
Ulster who who through Joe the lead
officer in the policy team there's been
some of the aides on because there are a
significant number of observations
recommendations and proposed amendments
the Clark has indicated that that that
there are quite appreciative of the
input so far it would seem that there
when the the process started back in
2014
progress was was quite slow until the
beginning of 2017 when the new Clark
came in and there's been a step change
in the in the work and the group are
grateful for the response to our
response in the consultation and they're
going to engage closely with our
officers to bring bring those
recommendations forward there are some
significant issues around whether this
should be a joint NDP with kiloton
Parish and also the status of a
significant development site at Alamo
align and that does have implications
but broadly speaking members of the
cabinet are asked to endorse the
schedule of comments and recommendations
outlined in the report and that those
then be taken forward so that the NDP
group in Oster can work
second draft any other questions if not
to the recommendation Thank You
councillor Pemberton I think it is quite
heartening that the Ulster Town Council
will work closely with officers to move
this forward so with that the
recommendation on page 237 can I have
your approval to that recommendation
members of cabinet thank you
moving on parts a no issues arising from
over the in scrutiny committee part d on
block items covenant work program which
has been circulated strategic policy
advisory group minutes and member
development working group minutes these
are I believe for noting so can we note
these note I'll receive these please
members of cabinet agreed thank you
there is no urgent business so I now
move to item 23 on the agenda which is
the exclusion of the public so I have to
say that
pursuant to section 100 a brackets for
of the Local Government Act 1972
brackets as amended the public be
excluded from the remaining business of
the meeting and view of the fact that
the nature of the proceedings will be
such that if the public were present
there would likely be disclosure to them
of exempt information on the paragraph 5
of Hart warned of chedi will 12a to the
said act as amended
so the agenda constitutes the five day
notice period required by regulation 5
so with that I move on to item 24